Art is an elusive specter.
It can be harder to catch than SCP-682, harder
to explain than SCP-055, and have as profound
effects on our minds as SCP-035.
It exists in our hearts and our brains.
It’s something we can both discover and
impose.
Paintings, sculptures, performance, music,
film, photography, animation, game design,
and so much more exists under its umbrella.
Thomas Merton once said, “Art enables us
to find ourselves and lose ourselves at the
same time.”
And we here at SCP Explained are inclined
to agree.
Even the video you’re watching right now
is a kind of art: It’s the product of hard
work by writers, editors, animators, a voice
artist, and the producers who bring it all
together.
Really, where would we be without it?
But of course, there’s always going to be
people out there who want to push the boundaries
of art just that little bit further.
The avant-garde artists who work on the fringes,
pioneers willing to delve further into the
darkest corners of human experience - And
sometimes even beyond.
That’s right, welcome to the wonderful and
weird world of Anartists - A word that, in
and of itself, has a kind of artistry to it.
It’s short for Anomalous Artists - As in,
artists who work with the medium of explicitly
anomalous objects or materials.
The more perceptive among you may also have
noticed its similarity to the word “Anarchists”,
as in, rejectors of rigid rules and order
- like the kind imposed by the SCP Foundation.
And when it comes to the world of Anartists,
you’ll find that a certain group comes up
again and again and again: Are We Cool Yet?
You’ve probably heard it before in passing,
but there’s a lot about this anomalous art
collective that remains mysterious…
Until today.
We’re going to grab our berets and paint-stained
aprons and dive deep into the Anart scene,
as well as their most controversial group
of interest.
One thing is for sure: It’s going to get
incredibly, incredibly strange from here on
in.
But hey, it’s art, what can you expect?
The structure and reputation of Are We Cool
Yet?
Is a complicated and contentious topic even
within the world of Anart.
Much like the Serpent’s Hand, the group
is incredibly decentralized, with no governing
body or binding ethos, save for the commitment
to producing Anart.
Proponents of Are We Cool Yet?
think of it as a kind of binding ethos.
Someone can become a member of Are We Cool
Yet?
Without even knowing about the group beforehand.
This is why, as long as the memory and reputation
of the group remains alive, the SCP Foundation
can’t effectively shut them down.
Some work under the banner of Are We Cool
Yet?
Alone, toiling away, driven by sheer passion
for the art they create.
Others work in creative salons, typically
led by a smaller group of artistic visionaries,
working to turn their combined skills into
more ambitious varieties of Anart.
A common philosophy of the group is wanting
to make their art visible to the world, often
to make a statement or start a discussion
among the public.
Naturally, this particular drive is liable
to make local Foundation authorities burst
a blood vessel.
Or maybe they really don’t just get art?
I mean, look at Dr. Gears, especially.
Does he strike you as the kind of guy who
would take some time out of his day to stroll
around a gallery?
He’d probably murmur some snide comment
about it being a waste of printing paper.
Ahem.
Anyway, before we proceed any further into
Are We Cool Yet?
As it is today, its relationship with other
groups of interest, its splinter cells, and
some of the notable creations its members
have produced, we need to go back to the past
and discuss the group’s creation.
Thankfully, this group’s history can be
traced back to the 1800s rather than us needing
to trace it all the way back to the creation
of humanity and the universe, like the Church
of the Broken God or the Children of the Scarlet
King.
The rather amazing thing about this particular
group is that its whole identity can be traced
back to an argument between two famous artists:
Marcel Duchamp and Ruiz Marcos.
For those who need a little refresher on art
history, Duchamp’s most famous pieces are
probably Fountain, the iconic signed urinal
and
L.H.O.O.Q., the painting of the Mona Lisa
defaced with a mustache and goatee.
And Ruiz Marcos is best known for painting
the colors in your darkest nightmares, that
strange feeling you get at an empty train
station in the middle of the night, and the
subtle whiff of burnt toast you get before
a cerebral event.
The following is a critcal extract from The
Coolest War: Memories of a Critic, an anonymously-penned
opus on the nature of Anart and the creation
of Are We Cool Yet?, detailing the group’s
early history and defining embryonic moments.
“In the nineteenth century, the march of
progress made it possible for the first time
for human science to contemplate and comprehend
those phenomena which had long seemed to contravene
the laws of nature.
Within a matter of decades, concepts that
had long been viewed as witchcraft or sorcery
were laid bare in the terms of a new and secret
science, and governments and organizations
around the world began to classify, study,
and collect all such anomalies.
And, just as artists throughout history have
turned a critical eye to the events of the
day in their work, so too did the artists
of this scientific Renaissance begin to interpret
these new discoveries on canvas.
By the 1870s, Paris was the center of the
world of anomalous art, and the city stood
witness to endless debates about the role
of the anomalous in art, or whether such a
role existed at all.
When in 1874 the famed Salon des Magnifiques
refused to allow any "works of a phantasmagorical
nature" to be displayed at their grand exhibition,
those artists shut out by the committee organized
their own counter-exhibition, to be held at
the same time across the river.
"Sommes-Nous Devenus Magnifiques?", as the
show came to be called, was the talk of the
Parisian press for months, earning equal amounts
of curiosity, dismissal, and outright derision,
but the exiled gadflies had made their point
- the paranormal, the anomalous, and the bizarre
had found a place in the world of art and
would not be so easily gotten rid of.
"Sommes-Nous Devenus Magnifiques?"
held its exhibitions every ten years thereafter,
and as time passed the world of anomalous
art grew larger.
From its beginnings in Paris, artists from
all across France and Europe, and later from
the Americas and the Orient as well, began
attending the increasingly prestigious - and
increasingly bizarre and difficult to keep
hidden from the disdainful eyes of a concerned
government - exhibition, expressing new and
different interpretations of the role of the
anomalous in human life.
It was at the sixth decennial exhibition in
1924 that the growing rift between the two
largest schools of thought - logical vs. emotional,
science vs. faith, Old World vs. New - came
to a head, for it was at that show that for
the first time, the works of the French surrealist
Marcel Duchamp would be exhibited alongside
those of Ruiz Marcos, the Mexican artist whose
themes of magical realism and religious awe
intertwined with the viscerally accessible
Forteana of our world had set art critics
worldwide at war with each other.
Those who saw the two during the days leading
up to the opening of the exhibition said they
spent nearly the entire time in heated discussion
with one another (in English, for neither
spoke the other's mother tongue confidently)
about everything under the Sun - the importance
of the artist in relation to his work, the
importance of context, faith, knowledge, law,
free will, God, the State, democracy, Marxism,
the war, the League of Nations, and the best
way to serve a cup of coffee.
It seemed that they might continue bickering
throughout the entire exhibition, but as the
artists prepared to greet the assembled press
on the morning of its grand opening, they
appeared to have eventually come to an understanding.
If there is one image that comes to the mind
of any art historian when the 1924 Expo is
brought up, it is of that iconic photo of
Duchamp and Ruiz posing side by side with
their fellow artists in front of the still-closed
doors, Marcos seemingly leaning over to whisper
something into Duchamp's ear.
For decades, many have speculated on what
words Marcos had for his colleague during
that memorable instant; a question of metaphysics?
Or a challenge?
An affirmation of their coming to terms?
A reminder of the reason why they were there
at that moment of time?
Perhaps an expression of amazement at the
multitudes that had come to see them?
According to one reporter who claimed he stood
close enough to overhear that whisper amidst
the din of the crowd, it was all five at once,
expressed in four simple words;
"Are we cool yet?"”
As you can see, the themes that run through
the entirety of this group of interest got
their starts early on.
The leading ones are conflict and the desire
to prove oneself.
Being excluded from the prestigious 19th-century
French art salon, Salon des Magnifiques, led
to them creating their iconic gathering and
exhibition: Sommes-Nous Devenus Magnifiques?,
which translates loosely to “Have We Become
Magnificent?”
- An ironic jab about gatekeeping in the art
world.
To have one’s Anart featured at Sommes-Nous
Devenus Magnifiques?, held only once every
ten years, is the greatest honor for any artist
that is a devotee of Are We Cool Yet?
And their practices.
However, something that is extremely important
to note is that this doesn’t necessarily
apply to all Anartists out there.
After all, Anartists, like all creative spirits,
have a tendency to be highly individualistic,
and some have bones to pick with the way that
Are We Cool Yet?
Operates.
One notable splinter group broke away in 2013,
to form a far smaller group of interest known
as Gamers Against Weed.
The Gamers didn’t exactly jive with the
fact that some of the Anart made by members
of Are We Cool Yet?
Hurt people.
Specifically, the founder of Gamers Against
Weed, Jude Kriyot, lost a friend to a dangerous
piece of Anart at an Are We Cool Yet?
Exhibition.
The Gamers also just found that Are We Cool
Yet?
Had a weirdly intense energy that seriously
harshed their vibe, and as a result, they
went in their own direction to perform more
harmless and goofy anomalous pranks - Like
creating SCP-3108, the Nerfing Gun, and SCP-2586,
Mr. Literal Serial Killer.
And we swear that’s less nasty than it sounds!
The violence that this particular art collective
allows is a point of contention among a lot
of Anartists.
Some ex-members have joined the more pacifistic
sects of the Serpent’s Hand, where they
can still follow their dreams of exposing
the anomalous to the public, without needing
to rub elbows with the kind of people who
believe that art projects have a certain amount
of “acceptable casualties.”
Naturally, because of their laissez-faire
attitude towards death and destruction as
well as their commitment to making sure their
unique Anart is seen by the world, Are We
Cool Yet?
Is actively despised by The SCP Foundation,
the Global Occult Coalition, the FBI’s Unusual
Incidents Unit, and the Horizon Initiative.
Confirmed members are to be arrested, contained,
and questioned for further information on
sight.
Dr. Wondertainment is a lot more amicable
with members of Are We Cool Yet?
After all, a lot of artists aren’t quite
able to pay their bills on their passion projects
alone, and as much as the “starving artist”
is a romanticized concept, these people do
still really need to eat.
So there are definitely worse things an aspiring
Anartist can do than take a part-time design
job with the fine folks at the Dr. Wondertainment
Toy Company.
They utilize the inherent creativity and anomaly-making
skills of these desperate Anartists to create
their most delightfully devilish toys yet.
And there’s no shame in that - After all,
Salvador Dali did some work with Disney and
designed candy logos.
We all have our side gigs!
Members and cells of Are We Cool Yet?
Have also had documented links to some of
the more powerful and dangerous groups of
interest out there.
On the more mild side of this new spectrum,
there’s HANSARP, a German dadaist and nihilist
group that was formed by members of Are We
Cool Yet?
Under the instructions of the Church of the
Broken God-affiliated leader, Boris Aldermann.
We may need to give a little extra context
here.
Dada or Dadaism, to give a brief and highly
reductive definition, is an early-20th century
art movement formed in the wake of the horrors
of World War One, which highly disapproved
of war, violence, and nationalism.
It sought to challenge the very boundaries
of art and what could really be considered
“art” in the first place - so naturally,
it has a lot of common philosophical ground
with the loose central ethos of the Are We
Cool Yet?
Movement.
And Nihilism is, in short, the belief in the
lack of any inherent meaning in life.
So it goes without saying that HANSARP are
some pretty intense folks.
But not nearly intense as Grand Karcist Ion
or the Scarlet King, and cells of Are We Cool
Yet? have been associated with both the Sarkicists
and the Scarlet King worshippers.
However, their relationships with some of
the Sarkicists they’ve dealt with have been
frosty, to say the least.
For example, in SCP-2714, an anomalous copy
of the Adventures of Tintin graphic novel,
members of Are We Cool Yet?
tricked a Sarkicist into trapping one of his
holy figures in the comic book, before killing
the poor sap’s father.
A lot of creators suffer for their art, but
the really unpleasant folks make other people
suffer for their art, and Are We Cool Yet?
has plenty of those.
Another Are We Cool Yet?
cell known as Cool Yet Radio, which focused
on making audio-based anomalous art pieces,
created SCP-4150, a version of the classic
Beatles song Penny Lane with a cognitohazardous
effect added.
Intriguingly, this song contains a lyric referencing
the Seventh King, which is believed to be
a nod to - you guessed it - the ever-unpleasant
nightmarish chaos god, The Scarlet King.
There are truly all kinds of members of Are
We Cool Yet?, covering an extremely wide spectrum
of beliefs.
But I think we’ve heard more than enough
about the artists for now.
How about instead, we have our own little
Sommes-Nous Devenus Magnifiques?
Exhibition right here, and take a look at
some of Are We Cool Yet?’s finest pieces
of anomalous art.
Of course, the non-anomalous world is no stranger
to dangerous and provocative art pieces.
Performance artist Marina Abramović put herself
in real danger by involving knives and guns
in her performance piece Rhythm Zero, and
Ron Athey put himself at the mercy of a wig
full of needles to raise awareness of HIV
in his piece Self-Obliteration.
But no non-anomalous art piece will ever be
as deadly as SCP-173.
That’s right: The Sculpture is heavily theorized
to be a piece of deadly Anart created by a
powerful Anartist known as The Sculptor.
It’s believed to be a commentary on the
nature of humanity itself: An attention seeker
who only knows how to commit violence and
defecate.
For something a little less deadly, there’s
SCP-092, a collection of 3125 CDs each titled
“The Absolute Absolute Absolute Absolute
BEST of The 5th Dimension!!!!!”
This piece was created collaboratively by
the musical group 5th Dimension and a member
of Are We Cool Yet?
Anyone listening to the album is forced to
listen to every song in a row, at which point
anyone who listened will exclaim “Wow, that
was real cool.”
However, the artist felt this wasn’t their
finest work, and turned themself and the CDs
in to the SCP Foundation for voluntary containment.
Then there’s the commissioned piece SCP-2635,
the hot potato.
This was initially paid for by a Chechen Rebel
Group planning to take out their Russian enemies,
and the Anartist taking the commission was
happy to give it a theatrical and artistic
flair.
Any group that possesses the potato for more
than one calendar year will lose half of its
members, as they begin to spontaneously combust.
To keep these effects from occurring, it’s
continually passed between groups, living
up to its nickname as the hot potato.
Some great art can come out of spite.
A good example is SCP-4879, a soapstone polar
bear statue that has the frightening ability
to take away the special talents of anyone
standing in its proximity.
It was created by an Anartist filled with
spite at the success and talent of his fellow
artists and wished to take away their artistic
spark.
However, in what seems like a meditation on
the ultimately self-destructive nature of
spite, the very creation of SCP-4879 wound
up forever squashing whatever creative abilities
its creator had.
Then we have this little anomalous art taster
plate, the nightmare-inducing SCP-1057, a
kind of anti-shadow, a selectively tangible
shape that, despite technically not being
there, can behave and kill like an Adult Tiger
Shark.
And to make things even more frightening,
this beast was first found after it devoured
people in an otherwise normal swimming pool.
A note left by the antishark’s creator on
the swimming pool’s bulletin board read,
“Panic means that the idea of a shark can
be more dangerous than an actual shark.
It can be even more dangerous than no shark
at all.
Are we cool yet?”
And we’re sure that means…
Something.
There you have it, folks, our crash course
on the SCP Foundation’s most artistic enemy,
the Are We Cool Yet Collective?
And look, we’re not saying that the Chaos
Insurgency are nice people, but they at least
have the decency to not tell us we don’t
like their murderous site raids because we
“just don’t get it, man.”
Now go check out “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle
- The Full Story Compilation” and “SCP
Foundation Boss - The Administrator Explained”
for more from the weird, wild world of the
SCP Foundation!